would you please
talk about why getting rid of excess
stuff is so emotional for many of us
i'm ready and i'm actively doing it but
i cry
letting go of so many things it hurts to
let go
man so i'm sorry that you're hurting i
totally i
understand it though um it's weird
because
as we let go that's when we we start
giving meaning to things even more
yeah we give them more meaning than they
we initially gave them
although i've already said that the
things don't have meaning themselves
we've given the thing some meaning but
then when it's time to let go
we overvalue that meaning even greater
right yeah and so my pithy answer for
you angela is
letting go of stuff hurts only when we
conflate
material with meaning and it's you know
easier said than done right man
i mean it's like i got that stein that i
talk about often that my grandma gave me
from high school
yeah ben stein it just it holds up you
know it's from germany it's it's got
dakota arms from where you know our
family comes from and lawsuit germany
and i use it there for my change and you
know it's
it is i do i don't want to say overvalue
it but you know if it broke
you know if it's spontaneously combusted
i would i would probably flinch
but ultimately uh because
you know you and i have been practicing
uh not
creating these emotional bonds with
things that uh the flinch wouldn't last
as long so i guess i'm just
not trying to make it sound super super
easy it is it's definitely difficult but
the more you practice the easier it is
but here's my pithy answer i would say
create an emotional bond with people
not things i mean it's very similar to
our love people use things
but that's exactly why we say that yeah
is because what you said earlier
sometimes we overvalue things and when
we were talking to peter that's what
love is
love is overvaluing something and if we
are overvaluing material possessions we
are falling in love with our things
and if that's what we choose to
perpetuate that feeling that emotion
that connection with a thing
i mean we have to realize what that what
that connection is actually going to do
to us
totally agree